[Music]
in the world of comic book artists Alex
Ross is a superhero he's been called the
Norman Rockwell of comics and has put
his imprint on Superman and spider-man
Aquaman and Captain America Ross wields
his superpowers in his paintbrush he
allowed us into his secret lair and so
here is where I keep all my toys or most
of them at least there's a lot of toys
yes the little Museum upstairs in Alex
Ross's home in the Chicago suburbs is
every comic book fans dream he spent a
lot of time in here no not really I but
it's a comfort that it's here it's a
comfort that it's here but this is
making up for a life where I had to ask
or beg for toys and so once I had money
and then I could buy everything I ever
wanted and it just never stopped this is
Alex Ross's world
he not only collects it he creates it in
nearly 30 years as an artist and
illustrator he's painted almost every
popular superhero his work for DC was
collected in the book mythology and his
work for Marvel has just been published
in more velocity is there a big
difference between drawing from for DC
and Marvel or is it essentially the same
job it's kind of a difference based upon
mood and vibe of the material there's
something about the stoic heroes a DC
that can be contrasted against the
hyperkinetic heroes of Marvel I knew
from whatever you might call it very
early age this is what I wanted to do
period I wanted to make art of
superheroes I wanted to you know sort of
live in their skin full-time if I could
as a kid he began sketching his
favorites even making paper action
figures this is just like construction
paper and yeah scotch tape yeah so
that's a photo of me from when I was six
years old in a second grade and this is
the t-shirt I was wearing in the photo I
loved the character of Captain Marvel my
mother saved the shirt all these years
that's is the axils here it's the actual
shirt and so as an adult I was able to
locate the original
artwork done by Neal Adams you've got
like everything so it's the whole circle
of life here and there there I am his
mother was a fashion illustrator she
became more my hero in the sense of
watching her go off and work and giving
me the idea of hey getting paid to do
this not strictly just for the medium I
wanted to be in but just getting paid to
draw like his mom Ross went to the
American Academy of Art in Chicago it
was there he developed the realist style
that would distinguish his superheroes
your version of Superman was meant to be
more lifelike right yeah yeah it's
supposed to respect kind of the aged
history of the character going back to
the original art style from the 40s this
thicker heavier version of the character
where he looked like he would really
beat the living hell out of somebody was
something that drew me in there's
something graphically interesting about
the Joe Shuster art style that way do
you feel an enormous responsibility when
you're dealing with a character that
iconic I feel a sense of responsibility
and passion because when you get an idea
in your head thinking that you can
contribute something that no one else is
recognizing you know it really charges
you up and when you pull it off well
then it makes you think that you're
right about everything which makes you
impossible to deal with it makes you
Superman no that's not his fault
no he's he doesn't think he's right
about everything it just happens to be
right about everything when Russ started
in the late 80s most comic book art was
drawn and then inked in but Ross wanted
to paint his superheroes and painted
work made what kind of difference on the
page it's like you're getting more
content added at you more detail more
illumination of the subject it's the
same thing that you're taking out of
seeing them in feature films now readers
responded he won the comic buyer's guide
fan award for favorite painter seven
straight years were you surprised at how
much notice it got it's a terrible thing
to say I wasn't right
that's really a testicle I'm sorry I
feel like I was waiting for somebody to
come and do this and I'd been following
comics my whole life or they've been
these wonderful painted covers of the
Hulk when I was a kid in the 70s that I
just started like man to read a whole
story that would look like that on the
inside would be fantastic well nobody
was doing that then but it has allowed
Alex Ross to live the life he always
imagined what does it meant to you to be
part of this it means everything you
know the fact that I could be
intertwined with it that it could fill
my days you know that's the joy still
experience I like to connect back to the
person I was in that thing that gave me
such joy as a kid such cool stuff and
can I tell you what his first book came
out a mythology I used to sit my son in
my lap we spent hours with that book
because he loved that he could see his
drawings as a kid and he could see them
now great story I love that he goes back
to that